[Music]
the nation of south africa appears to be
in
significant trouble tonight anarchy
across the country in the cities and
outside the cities for more what's
happening right now
we go to kenita hunter she is a
political editor at news 24 in south
africa she joins us from johannesburg
thanks so much for joining us tonight so
we're
experiencing this mostly on social media
people are seeing videos of what's
happening
in your country describe what's going on
right now if you would
well there has been three days of
unrelenting looting and violence in
areas around johannesburg as well as
durban and surrounding areas which you
see
uh started as protest uh
against the jailing of former president
jacob zuma
this was on wednesday last week
um by thursday there were sporadic
incidences of violence but over the
weekend this
intensified to what president sullivan
has now called a coordinated criminality
dozens of malls shopping centers
and now even warehouses and factories
have been completely looted by
thousands um of people uh uh
acro across the country um in these
around
these two major economic hubs
what you see is the police completely
overburdened unable to stop
these um violent and looting
scenes that unfolded in the country
with the president having to call in the
south african national defense force on
monday
to reinforce efforts by police there's
been
a thousand uh 200 people that have been
arrested
but 72 people have lost their lives so
far
so from this perspective you see we're
seeing we're
playing video of it on the screen right
now of entire shopping malls being
emptied
office buildings being looted as you
said factories burned
it looks like a big part of the economy
of the country is being destroyed
absolutely and it is devastating
to an economy that was already bruised
by curvat 19
unemployment uh is you know in the
region of almost 40 percent
um and the economy was struggling to get
off
its feet and now this is an added blow
particularly
to businesses along the coast um they i
mean
the situation is so bad in durban that
um there are concerns around food and
medicine security as a result
of the looting when you talk about
medicine
there has been concerns around attacks
on storage facilities that
hold covert 19 vaccines um this the
president
you know said is would really hamper
governments
government's
efforts to fight the pandemic
you know to give you an example just
this evening government announced that
633 people
died from the covet 19 pandemic um
and and you know we are in the grips of
a third wave yet what you see
is thousands and thousands of people
going out in the streets looting
anything from tvs
to fridges what a tragedy
um and a complex story and we'll be on
it queen hunter i appreciate you coming
on tonight thank you so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else